Captions will appear here.
Captions will
appear
here. Good night. We're
delighted to
have you with us tonight,
welcome to our
digital audience, as well. We're
coming
together on a very topical
discussion. In our
world, despite the advances of
technology and
commerce and enlightened
thought, more people
are displaced by conflict than
ever before in
recorded history.
The figures from the United
Nations refugee
report that was released last
week are
overwhelming. 65 million people
have been
forced from their homes by
political violence
and unrest and that's not
counting people who
are displaced by natural
disaster. The
largest number come from Syria
and Iraq, but
those places are hardly alone in
feeding this
Exodus. There's a surge of
migrants coming
from the Congo, smallo, South
Sudan, Nigeria,
Afghanistan, Haiti, and Colombia
.
25 million people are taking
refuge outside
of their country and the largest
part of this
flood are not coming to rest in
Europe as the
press might have you believe,
but in Turkey
and Lebanon and Jordan and
Ethiopia. Along
the way in seeking safety, 1 in
20 people
die. And nearly 100,000 children
have
attempted the journey on their
own. This is
the most staggering global
crisis we have
seen since WWII, and it's an
existential one.
One that calls into question the
adequacy of
many of our long-held thoughts
and ideas, our
ideas about welcome, about
citizenship, about
nation, and borders, about
Europe itself.
And that seems clear with the
shock of
yesterday's news that Great
Britain elected
to leave the European Union,
motivated in
large part by a fear of open
borders and
untramieled immigration, but of
course this
is not just Europe's problem. It
is ours,
too, and I don't just mean
economic
implications of Brexit. I'm
thinking about
the way that we are subject to
the same
forces. It's been made clear in
Donald
Trump's xenophobic proclamations
or this
week's Supreme Court decision
about illegal
searches that justis society
SO
otomey proclaimed:
It's been quite a week. In a
civil society,
artists and other creative
producers play a
critically important role in
helping guide us
through these complex situation,
they
function as    s
sensors. And that's what
tonight's
conversation is about. It's part
of our
Citizens and Borders initiative
which is a
series of discrete programs that
are
organized by curators and other
program
administrators are that offer on
displacement
displacement. : It's organized
by
S Cormier and
Jean-Paul Comey it's going to be
up until
October 10th. Another addition
to our
citizens border is an exhibition
that will be
opening on October 1st, it's
organized by Anderson in the
department of
architecture and design and will
explore
architecture in relationship to
global
refugee emergencies.
So tonight's event is
cosponsored by the
council on foreign relations,
which is
committed to global literacy,
and together
with the CFR, we welcome and
extraordinary
group of individuals to our
stage. The great
artist Bouchra Khalili herself,
philosopher
and professor of political
science and great
champion of open borders, Joe
Carens, a
specialist on Islamic law and
political
movements, and I'm afraid that I
have some
bad news, as well, which is the
extraordinary
writer and activist, Samar
Yazbek can't join
us because of visa difficulties.
She travels
on an official refugee status.
She happens a
French passport with an official
refugee
status and encountered
difficulties and we
weren't able to work through
them in time,
but she's very eager to join us
tonight to
address this audience and we're
keen to have
her, so we'll have her for a
while. Part of
the program, via Skype, and then
we'll bring
her back to the museum in the
early fall when
we can secure her visa.
So that's a great
disappointment, but I'm
very glad she'll be able to join
us via
technology.
And the run of the program will
be that
everyone will come to stage,
Bernard will
begin the conversation with
Samar on Skype. discussion will
be about 50 minutes, then
there will be time for Q & A,
about 20
minutes of Q & A, you have cards
in your
program and you can write any
questions that
come up during the conversation
on your
cards, and you can also send us
questions
with the hashtag citizens
borders and you can
comment on the event that way,
as well. So
thank you all for joining us,
we're delighted
to have you and I'm looking
forward to
tonight's event.
[applause]
Thank you.
Thank you very much for the
introduction, and for the
invitation. We have
Samar here with us. And also
being an
academic, I got the books.
[laughter]
And Samar has two wonderful
books that we'll
be discussing today, among other
issues, the
first is." A woman in the
crossfire" which is
a book about her experience at
the beginning
of the Syrian uprising and the
second is "The
crossing" which is the journey
out of Syria
because of the war, so hello Sam
Samar.
>> So I will begin the question
by asking
you, the role of the artist in
talking about
these conflicts, in you know,
being a witness
to these conflicts, can you tell
us something
about that role and in
particular, drawing
from your own experiences?
(translator
speaking.)
Translator:  I believe that art
is against
death and against war.
Regarding that tragic
situation now in Syria
,
it is a situation
that was very important to all
the
identities, the different
aspects of the
identity of the artist.
It could be like
different like aspects. It could
be like
political activist and it could
be like an
activist or it could be like a
witness for
the truth.
(Samar speaking).
Translator:  One of the most
important things
that came to me at the beginning
of the
peaceful demonstrations in
Syria, around like
five years ago ...
(Samar speaking in Arabic)
Arabic).
Translator:  I was at the
front line at the
beginning of all of these
demonstrations and
I was really very keen to try to
convey the
really true picture right from
the beginning
to the media.
(Samar speaking in Arabic).
Translator:  Even when I moved
like -- when I
went like to Paris and then I
went back again
to the north in 2012 ...
Samar speaking
Prep (Samar speaking).
Translator:  As a writer, and
as a cultured
person, also, I was eager just
to be a part
of this change.
(Samar speaking).
Translator:  And lass in that
case,                      Also
in that case I was just
trying to document everything
that was going
on in the north and also to
establish a civil
establishment.
(Samar speaking).
Translator:  I was there in all
of these
areas that was under like
bombardment from
the Assad regime.
And I was in the front line
in all of these battlefields
where there was
also this presence of the ISIS,
also, and
after that I went back to Paris.
(Samar
speaking).
Translator:  And I have like
really horrible
life stories about all of these
people that
really lost their lives.
And they are the silent, like
they are
silent, all of these factors,
and they have
no -- no voice for them. They
were really
silent.
Samar speaking)
.
Translator:  And this is one
of the roles of
the artist during like wars or
like dramatic
changes in history. And this is
at least from
my perspective.
If I may, one of the issues
that actually
unites a lot of the work that's
being
presented here is the rejection
of the
typical or the stereotypical
framing of the
conflict, whether in your case
it's the
sectarian way in which Syria is
described as
explaining all the problems, or
in the case
of Bouchra, you know, the
stereotypical idea
that we have of the refugee is
also
interrogated in your work. And
is put into
question. And I would like us
perhaps to talk
about how the artist actually,
you know,
shifts the focus on what the
problem is as it
is defined, for example, in the
media.
(Translator speaking to Samar.)
(Samar speaking)
.
Translator:  After like in the
situation of
Syria, after like it was like
that way for
part of that field ...
it's very important
for the artist himself to be
part, one of the
tools of the change.
Samar speaking.
Translator:  But in my
situation, of course,
the arts, like all of the arts
was really
retreating in my situation
whatever was going
on in Syria was a little bit
retreating.
(Samar speaking).
Translator:  This relies on --
I think it is
for each artist and what is the
relation
between him and the society.
(Samar speaking)
.
Translator:  It was like really
we should not
fight for this, the fear, like,
the fear case
of the Syrian people.
(Samar speaking).
Translator:  We, as artists, we
were part of
this, like the demand for
democracy, and the
demanding for peace and we just
were part of
it as an artist.
(Samar speaking
)
.
Translator:  As I said, like
also as a
writer, also with so many
identities, I
should be also like, I should
have a part of
the change that's going to
happen in Syria,
about the change in Syria.
(Samar speaking)
.
Translator:  That will we should
not really
limit the function of the art,
because this
is not like really -- limiting
is no good,
like, we should not really limit
the role of
the art.
(Samar speaking)
.
Translator:  One of the most
important
things, really, is to try and
convey the
truth and to be the voice of all
of the
victims.
(Samar speaking).
Translator:  Because I am
believing of course
about the word of media and also
the Syrian
regime of course conveyed the
wrong image of
what's going on in Syria.
Samar speaking
.
Translator:  I was just to be
part of that,
just to be bring justice to all
of the
victims.
>> Should you see your role
in similar
terms, that you're a witness to
events that
you're trying to reframe how the
media talks
about refugees, for example? How
do you see
what you're doing?
>> I mean I absolutely agree
with what Samar
just said, and at the same time,
I stick with
my own position that is quite
different,
because I work within a
different context,
I'm not Syrian, and my
experience is
completely different, and an
artist also
works with one's own life and
own experience.
So I won't define my work or
myself as an
artist as a witness, but rather
as someone
who tries to ask a question, to
give the form
to that question, and rather
than speaking
for the others, giving that
opportunity to
individuals who are often
silenced to speak
for themselves, and with their
own words. But
at the same time, it's also what
Samar was
saying about providing with
different images,
and you started your question
with the
comparison, with the media. The
media often
produce images to illustrate the
discourse.
My position is somehow the
complete opposite
of that. It's whether -- how one
can ask a
question, rather than
illustrating a
solution, or a predefined or a
preconceived
discourse.
So I don't see myself as
someone proposing
something that is complete, but
rather asking
the question through an
audience, and
inviting the audience to reflect
on the
pictures that are shown and the
words that
are said and not giving one
solution, but
rather encouraging a dialogue
and a debate in
a public space, because a museum
is also a
public space, it's a space for
the public and
consequently it can be a civic
space, as
well. So that's also the reason
why I do not
define myself as an activist but
rather as a
citizen. Which is a different
position, but
try to look at images as
something that can
create a debate, a dialogue, in
other ways of
saying, and suggest other
perspectives, but
at the same time, not imposing
them, but
rather, suggesting them to the
public and
inviting the public to exercise
its freedom
of reacting to an artwork and
reflecting for
themselves through that artwork
and
eventually speaking of it with
others. So the
impact on reality is not direct,
but
it par
dissipates in the public debate.
But I also
work with very specific
questions with a very
singular trajectory that cannot
become
examples to the media, often
when they give
one minute or two minutes to
someone to
express himself or herself, that
person is
supposed to illustrate one
specific case. But
I don't believe that there are
examples, that
individuals trajectories are
examples. They
are what they are, they speak
for themselves,
and at the same time they are
universal.
>> There is definitely a
universality and I
know, Joe, you got to see the
installation
earlier. And the story that
seems to be
universal are people from so
many different
countries all trying to
delineating their own
itinerary ies on this map and
all the ethical
issues that arise. I mean some
of them end up
almost enslaved in country, in
several
different countries and what
would he would
normally think as a journey that
would take
10 hours and a flight takes
three years, four
years, sometimes, to complete.
>> Yeah.
>> I wonder what your sort of
response,
given the work you've done on
refugees, on
citizenship, on borders, how
that -- how that
installation spoke to you.
>> Well, I found it very
powerful. And for
precisely the reasons that
Bouchra just said,
the kind of specificity, the
tracking of the
individuals, so it's a -- doing
the sort of
work that Bouchra does as an
artist is
different from the sort of work
that I do as
a philosopher. We paint pictures
with words
and not like novelists, but
there is a way in
what you do as a philosopher is
try to
construct a vision of the world
and say isn't
it like this? So it's an appeal
to a debate
but it's an attempt to use
reason and
argument, so in that sense it's
a -- I think
there's less -- I do try to tell
some stories
and I actually think of them as
examples, so
there are some tensions here,
because I'm
trying to seek generalization,
so in a way,
what I'm doing is quite
different from
Bouchra, because I do want to
generalize. If
one engages in a debate, then
one wants to
have an answer. So a question
has to be posed
and I think she's quite good at
challenging
the questions. But then a new
must be
question must be posed and I'm
good at also
subverting the questions and I
think
Bouchra's work does a good job
at that.
>> Absolutely. And I know that
the medium
that you chose --          chose
--
[mumbling]
The medium that you chose is
the map and you
don't see.
>>
so I was wondering about
the, you
know, the choices that you made,
where, for
instance, you choose not to show
their faces,
and you chose the map. And I
know from an
article that was written about
your work
where you had shown or you had
discussed this
wonderful map, Medieval Islamic
map which
shows Europe in the south and
Africa in the
north, so a total inversion. Why
the map? Why
did you choose the map as this,
or
cartography as a way of talking
and
describing the questions and the
eye continue
itinerary.
>> I think my answer will be
quite long.
[laughter]
>> There are basically -- I
would say three
reasons. The first one is what I
have
witnessed myself when I was a
teenager in
Morocco. It's quite ironic to
think of it
today on the Brexit day, but I
was in Morocco
when the agreement was signed
and this had
immediate consequence on most
Africans,
because before then, it was easy
to go to
Europe. There was no need for a
visa. And
this completely changed at the
moment when
Europe was discussing the no
border for
Europe. It's not for the others.
So suddenly
we became excluded from that
area, from a
precise geographical area. For
us in 1991 the
problem was not in getting a
visa, it was not
having a passport. Because
having a passport
was a privilege. It was at the
discretion of
the state, who could decide who
could have a
passport and who could not. From
'91 it
became the opposite. It was
extremely easy to
have a passport and extremely
difficult to
have a visa. So I guess my
interest in
geography started also with
this. With the
contemplation of ancient Islamic
tradition of
map-making because that was also
what I was
in contact with, but also with
my own
experience of living in a
country where
suddenly we were banned to cross
borders. Why
the distance between Morocco and
Spain is 14
kilometers, and not to mention
the history of
with Spain, if we were to go
back in history.
So I guess the interest started
with this.
With the question of perception,
and the set
of complications to the
perception when I
started to live myself as an
immigrant in
France. So I had somehow the
contra view or
of being in that place that was
refused to us
before, and living there as
someone who was
not a citizen still. Even though
I could
speak French fluently, because
of course the
colonial history had an impact
on the
independence until today. French
is still a
prominent language in Morocco.
So it was as
if I was not living in a
completely unknown
country. There was a connection
between those
places, but still I was not a
citizen. I was
a foreigner. And I --      I --
when I became an artist
of course I also started to work
with this,
with my own experience, my own
perception of
the question. And being an
artist when I
start working on a project, I
also start
somehow formulating a question
and how to
give a visual shape to the
question. And that
is an image. It's a convention.
It's an
image. We all know map from our
books, etc.,
it's a familiar picture. But
what about that
picture
pick if that picture is
challenged by real
experiences? What about if that
picture
becomes a sort of surface on
which a sort of
contra map can be drawn? So for
me it was an
idea was very simple. I want to
show
something to someone. How can I
show it?
Because eventually when one
works with video
or film it's always about
showing something
to someone. It doesn't mean that
showing that
thing, you will say it means
this, or this is
what the picture is about. But
you show
something and you expect an
answer. And
that's also why I chose a map,
because the
map is also in a sense datic,
because it
shows something and when you
show a hand
drawing on a map it's also a
performative
gesture. You're showing
something. So the
idea of working with the map was
somehow
natural, because of my own
commitment with
geography, conception, but also
cinematic in
a sense that in one long shot I
had the shot
and the contra shot. There was
no need for
technical editing. The editing
was already
there because of the different
layers that
are combined. That's a, yeah,
visual shape.
And of course the voice plays
also a
prominent aspect, because it's
not -- I mean
it cannot be defined as: Because
it's
completely synchronized, but
that sound is
also an image, and that's how
the position of
the viewer becomes extremely
important,
because there is something that
is being
shown, and there is something
that is being
narrated, and they are all the
peculiarities
peculiaruleis
of one voice. Because every
specific voice
has a different brain, there are
accents.
Three of the videos are Arabic
and there are
different Arabic, so for an
Arabic speaker
it's also challenging to realize
how diverse
the Arabic is in a region that
is depicted as
completely homogeneous, which is
not true.
And I can give more and more
details on why
every single thing is extremely
specific, but
at the same time, very
simple.
>> The story of the * you know,
of the
intimate stranger, you know, in
the case of
the Moroccan or the north
African who comes
to Europe and speaks French but
is still
having to be made into someone,
an othering,
this is a story that also comes
out in your
work that you see these norms
when they're
constructed, often there's
something very
contrived and arbitrary about
them and you
have this wonderful story, I
mean tragic
story, actually, in the chapter
on refugees,
where it's a story of Jewish
refugees from
the Holocaust who are not
allowed into the
United States, and then the ship
is sent back
and presumably most of them
perish in Europe.
And the arguments that were
being made at the
time about these people, which I
mean there's
almost an immediate and direct
echo to how
we, you know, listen to people
who are
talking about Muslims or talking
about people
from the global south. There's
something so
familiar about that voice from
the '30s and
now again today, and I know that
you were
telling me earlier in your work,
that it
seems that the situation is only
getting
worse as you've been studying
these issues
over the last several decades.
Why do you
think that is? I mean not just
why is it
getting worse but why are these
echoes, these
trajectories so similar? Why is
it that we
never seem to learn to change
how we talk
about these others?
>> I wish I had an answer to
that. I do
think it is -- so first of all
I'm not a
complete pessimist. I think
these things
shift and you do sometimes find
an opening,
and a willingness to understand.
And I
actually think a lot of these
things are
contagious, that it just depends
on a set of
circumstances and who makes the
argument. I
mean we just went through an
election in
Canada in which there was a
right-wing party
that was taking the kind of
conventional,
anti-refugee and a kind of
mainstream but
liberal party and said we should
take in more
refugees and they loved it. So
it's an appeal
to a certain kind of identity
and that's what
I thought in the book in the
section on
refugees, so if you ask people
in North
America, Canada, the United
States about the
history of the Holocaust,
everyone would say
that was terrible, we failed,
this was a
terrible moral failure and exact
ly right, the
language when you looked at how
people
justified that at the time, how
is it that
they explained to themselves, it
was already
to exclude Jewish refugees, why
to deny them
visas, why to accuse them of
being smugglers,
if they have this much money,
they can't
really be in need. And all of
the same
arguments, they're dangerous,
some of them
may be communists. Some of them
are actually
Nazis, but they're pretending to
be Jewish.
All of the same arguments that
you hear today
were the arguments that were
made at that
time and my hope is that by
drawing attention
to that, people will come to see
that there's
something problematic about the
discourse
that is dominating the
discussion of refugees
today, and I do think it's
contingent, that
if enough people see it and hear
it, we have
both of these forces out there.
You saw that
in Germany, right? There was a
very positive
response to the refugees, and
then some
negative things and it's not
predetermined.
It's not fixed. And it matters
what people
say.
>> Although the legal
structures and the
legal norms seem not to have
been updated to
deal with this reality, or at
least the
intensity of the refugee crisis
that we're
seeing today.
>> Right.
>> And one of your pleas in the
book is to
actually lessen that.
>> Yes and no. I think if you
had said what
would be
the right frame to admit
refugees,
you would have a much more
expansive
definition. And I deed you
indeed you see some
progress.
It has been expanded to exclude
persecution
on the basis of gender,
sexuality. Those were
not envisaged when they wrote
the rules. But
in other ways it's been narrowed
and
constrained. And I do have to
say that I
would not, as a -- if I were
recommended to
policymakers, I wouldn't
recommend opening up
the definition now, because in
this climate
what would happen is it would be
narrowed
further still, so ... although
the definition
as it currently is imperfect, if
you tried to
make it better, it would
probably make it
worse. So there's a difference
what you think
in principle and what actions
you take in the
world. You have to think about
the
consequences of the actions.
>> And are you still engaged in
some of
these issues around -- I know
that you know,
you don't really like to talk
about the work
you're doing, but are you still
engaged in
some of these questions, big
questions about
identity, borders, citizenship,
belonging?
>> Somehow I always considered
that my work
was not necessarily about
refugees or
migrations, it was whether sort
of
integration and what this means
to be a
citizen. Including when the law
doesn't give
you the right to be a citizen.
Is it still
possible to consider society
where anyone can
be a citizen or in more simple
words, can we
consider citizenship not as an
exclusive
club, which membership is your
ID card, but
something completely different
that would be
a commitment to society. And
the only condition that would be
demanded by
a state that recognized someone
as a citizen.
But to go back to your previous
questions, if
you ask a question of
alternative forms of
citizenship, you also integrate
to society
the state, and what it means
today, and I
guess the process is also
integrate the
nation state and what it means,
and the
Brexit somehow is a sort of
victory of the
most conservative conception of
what is a
nation state, as opposed to the
Europe union
that was supposed to be not an
addition, but
a sort of combination of nation
states that
somehow go over various
conceptions of
belonging to the point of
bringing the
opposite of Europe citizenship,
but that
depends on everything that could
be more
inclusive somehow and what we
are seeing
today is also the failure of
that. The
failure of that utopia, so maybe
my work is
eventually about dysutopia or
citizenship not
being to nation states, but to
other forms of
belonging, and I guess that's
the reason why
these last few years, I went
back to the
history of
-- ... because there was a time
when the nation state was not
defined as a
horizon of independence, but
more a set of
perception of the world as a
coalition of a
political utopia, and that was
enough to
consider that I can support a
Vietnamese in
his independence or somebody
from South
Africa, etc., etc., and of
course I
understood that I had an impact
on that,
because I understood that I was
confused by
the way it was pictured in the
media as the
face of revolution. As the
history of
revolution, needed modern and
western
technology to become possible.
But there's a
very long history of
revolutionary thinking
and progressive thinking in the
area, so I
have dedicated the last few
years in somehow
investigating that history, and
articulate ing
different moments in the history
of the
region when that utopia was
somehow
implemented or discussed. At
least discussed
in a very concrete way. And to
answer your
question, I'm currently working
actually on
two projects, one that will be
the closing
shop somehow and the investigate
and the
history of utopia
but more -- it actually
starts with a French writer and
the
... And
another project about theater
and community,
and again, what would be at
stake is the
question of belonging. And a
community. What
is a community. And what is a
community that
aims to achieve equality? And of
course this
results in many problems,
including
decisionmaking and etc. when
you're in a
group, if you want to be an
equal in the way
you function, you have to invent
ways of
making decisions so I'm giving
here specific
examples of this to give you an
idea of why
it is together. And it will be a
film that
will be produced in a theater
with nonact
ors.
And involving different people
from different
backgrounds. But it also
originates in a real
story.
>> In a real story?
>> Yeah. But I cannot say more
than that.
[laughter]
>> Can I say something more
about Bouchra's
projects that I found really
moving and
effective? So in my book I say
that the
modern nation state, the rich
western modern
states, are like -- it's a form
of feudalism,
really, to be born in a rich
western modern
state is to be born in know
built in the
middle ages and to be born
anywhere else
world -- even though lots of us
are not
mobility. And to be born into
the poor states
is like to be born into the
peasant states.
And it's that way because then
your life
chances are so dependent on
where you're
born, and one of the things that
comes out in
the mapping project is you can
see these are
just ordinary people, you know
that the
immigrants get constructed as
threats and
dangerous and trying to take
stuff from us,
and you can see -- and it's --
the simplicity
of it because you don't know a
lot about the
story, you just have a map
tracing, but this
voice saying, well I went from
here, and I
was looking for work and so I
went there, so
these are just ordinary people,
trying to
find jobs, trying to make a life
for
themselves and that comes out I
think very
vividly in the way in which all
these
different stories reflect that
and they then
call into question the
legitimacy of
exclusion. So why do we get to
say no to
these people? Why are we
entitled to what we
have in the United States and
Canada and in
these European states? Why do we
get to keep
them out? What is the foundation
for that and
that's what I think kind of
comes out in your
project.
>> I absolutely agree with your
comment and
I hoped that this would be
understood when
explaining the work, because
again what I
tried to reflect on this
conception of
citizenship that originates in
the conception
of nation state, meaning again
the
citizenship as a sort of VIP
area in a big
club, that the club is the world
and there's
the VIP area, and that's the
area where you
have the open part and the
others are at the
door and they cannot get in. And
to continue
your own idea with peasantry.
>> No, no, right.
>> And I became more and more
sensitive to
this, of course as someone who
was born as a
subject of the king and not as a
citizen,
because that's technically what
we were in
the early 2000s, and when I
lived in France
with a residency permit, I was
excluded from
the club in many, many different
aspects,
even though I was going to the
same schools
as the others. I was given the
same
education, I was speaking the
same language,
sharing the same culture, etc.
etc. etc.
etc., and of course this was
also reflected
in the daily discourse of French
politicians
as an example. So why should we
be surprise ed
that she is so popular, because
she's the one
claiming citizenship in an
exclusive club and
this should be the privilege of
the French
only, and therefore also giving
legitimacy to
a conception of French
citizenship that
somehow absolutely contradicts
the principle
of the French Revolution.
>> Right.
>> I was rereading the article
3, I think of
the French constitution of 1793,
which was
probably the most progressive
ever written in
that country and there's one
sentence,
absolutely beautiful that says,
"Every alien
who
each man or orphan is (much).
That's
enough. It's not about being
born in France
or spending five years or ten
years or
whatever, it's about being a
human being. And
France can give you French
citizenship to
someone who has demonstrate ed
great humanistic
things. Someone living in
Morocco, or Syria,
or I don't know, can become
French. So the
question can be also asked in
that way, why
are so-called progressive
democratic
countries became nation state on
the basis of
very open conception of
citizenship, and why
why -- and the complete
opposite. Somehow you
answered the question before,
when you
mentioned that the
instrumentation of
citizenship for a short-term
political agenda
by politicians in many western
countries
there's a wonderful play by a
French
historian on the history of
citizenship. It's extraordinary.
How it was
instrumentalized in the late
17th and 18th
Century and one understands that
there is a
sort of opportunistic agenda in
granting
citizenship to foreigners and
suddenly making
it more difficult to the exactly
same people,
and even worse than WWII.
>> I mean there is something --
there is
something to be said for what's
happening in
Europe, in particular. The
instrument
instrumentalization, and the
description of
the immigrant and the refugees
in particular,
as a real threat to national
identity, to the
collective itiy. Speaking from
the Middle East,
you see countries like Turkey,
Lebanon,
Jordan, even Saudi Arabia has
taken in
several hundred thousand
Syrians, and these
Syrian
refugees are not necessarily
treated
well, but they're not -- the
state doesn't
use them as a foil to construct
a sense of
identity, an exclusive sense of
identity in
opposition to that. And it's
curious that
that's not the case in the
Middle East, given
that they're taking in many more
than Europe
is.
>> So this is a, for me, you
know, laya
mentioned it in the opening and
you just
brought it up again. If you look
at the
debate that people say we can't
take them in
Europe or the United States,
10,000 that
would be too many, and Lebanon
has over a
million refugees, so this idea
that it's too
many, we can't manage, what is
it that people
imagine who say that is going to
happen to
these refugees? Do they think
they should die
and if not, who should take care
of them and
why should Lebanon take care of
them or
Turkey or Jordan. So there's
some confusion
with the implications. So if
you're saying
this, why does that imply for
what should
happen to these refugees? Who is
responsible?
And why do we assume that these
states, as
you say, these states in the
Middle East,
which are not a model, they are
often
undemocrattive and they are
oppressive in
many ways, but they are the ones
who are
admitting them and taking care
of them and
the rich liberal democratic
states are
excluding them. So I think
that's a deep
puzzle and contradiction in the
values that
we claim to profess.
>> That's absolutely true.
>> But I think -- I mean I
suspect that the
answer to that why that is has
to do with
politics. It doesn't have to do
with --
>> The answer has to do with
privilege,
right? That what people feel
that we will
have to give up some of the
privileges that
we enjoy and that is true, so if
you accept
this model of feudalism, then
mobility has to
give up some of its privileges.
Any yes, we
cannot enjoy all the privileges
that we have
in a just world. In a just
world, people
won't need to leave home to find
work,
because the opportunities will
be more widely
distributed. But then there's
kind of refusal
to acknowledge our role in
maintaining this
present order. Notice even in
your comments,
you know, we presuppose, and
that's one of
the things that Bush
Bouchra's mapping project
underlies. We proceed
presuppose a state. We take
those
as given entities. But there's a
way in which
one of the things that one want
to do is
problem advertise that. And what
if we wanted
to define organizing the world
into states,
what is the story we tell as to
why that's
good for everybody? Not just
good for us. You
have to say it's good for
everybody, right?
There has to be some story and
there isn't a
good story to tell about that.
>> And that would be through
geopolitics.
And we have learned this last
year that also
conducted to what is going on in
Syria and
other areas of the region when
you think of
acknowledging the situation. To
acknowledge
that the consequences of gee
geo political
agendas that are contemplated
and operated in
very specific areas lead to the
disasters
that we have been seeing in
Iraq, actually
for months and months and
months. We won't
speak only since 2003, because
between 2001
and 2003, a lot of refugees were
leaving out
of the consequence of the war.
And I met a
lot of them in Istanbul in 200
6, 7, so
speaking of equality is also
speaking of
geopolitics, and it's a true,
and extension
form, and that opportunistic
and cynical, and the
consequences to the neighboring
area, because that also what
happens, just to
give an example.
>> So I have a couple of
questions. One has
to do with, you know, the
individual that you
know, spoke to, and how you got
them to tell
their stories or the mechanics
of it. But
before I get into that, I'm
wondering about
the, again, in a way your
interrogation, your
questions are also a
representation of this
situation, that I know they were
done before
the Arab Spring, but really,
they could have
been done after the Arab Spring,
they would
have been done almost any time,
because the
story of these people trying to
leave, you
know, is decades old. Even from
the regions
where -- that they come from. So
in terms of,
you know, in a sense giving them
voice,
representing them, there's
something to me at
least that the artist does, and
certainly in
your case, it's almost
Christian, you know?
You almost put your finger on on
a problem
that exists, and told the story
of the
problem in a way that hasn't
been told by
anyone else. Certainly not by
the media.
There's something almost, you
know, as I said
prescient. You could tell that
this was a
problem that's very major in the
world today,
and you could tell that story in
a way that I
think is much more effective
than other ways
of telling it that are -- that
we hear about,
typically from the media. And so
the role of
the artist in that telling, if
you can maybe
say something about whether you
think you,
you know, you put your finger on
something in
any particular way, how is it
that you even
came up with this idea? Did you
notice it
from Morocco and it was
something you
experienced yourself? You wanted
to reproduce
it through these individuals, as
well, or was
it something else?
>>
>> Again, I can't make a short
answer to
this.
>> I'm sorry to ask you just
deep questions.
[laughter]
>> Even when I was in the art
school in
Paris, I was working on the
question of
being, of not being a citizen
and being
somehow excluded to the margin
of society,
because you don't hold the right
paper.
>> Right, mm-hm.
>> I guess it's something to
which I have
always been very attentive. My
own situation
was different because I was a
student, and I
moved with my parents, and I was
very lucky,
because often it's also a
complete conflict.
The first time I went to France
I was 3
months old and    . So when I
applied for a permit,
they said that I already came,
there was a
connection. It makes things
easier. But what
about if a different law was
written two days
before. It was -- at that time
it was easier.
Today it would be impossible. It
would never
happen. But 20 years ago, it was
possible for
someone like me, who did not
face that many
difficulties in getting a
residency permit.
But it was more difficult to
apply for
residency, which was a another
story. To go
back to your question, I cannot
answer it in
a simple way, because I cannot
say I have
experienced this myself the same
way. It's
not true. What I have experience
ed is
witnessing in my own
environment, and every
single Moroccan knew a lot of
people who
crossed the strait of
Gilbrat lter. And it
created a culture with songs,
jokes, music.
It is almost a
subculture because it was
massive in the early '90s until
the early
2000s.
>> So the journey, right?
>> Yeah, leaving? Leaving.
>>
>> We said burning.
>> Burning?
>> Yeah, because you burn the
--        the -- air abic.
Or he's a burner. He burned last
month.
That's what we used to hear
almost every day.
Hamad, he burned last night. So
that was
really in our environment. So of
course this
creates another perception of
crossing
borders illegally, not to
mention the history
of immigration that is
completely linked to
it and the authority of
immigration is very
strong. Because there's a huge
from Morocco,
all over the world and these
also participate
in that structure that I tried
to describe
before. I'm not sure actually if
I'm
answering your question, but I'm
trying to
connect very complex things
together that
somehow enrich that work in
particular. But
to say it in more simple words,
I worked with
what I knew. And I worked also
with what I
researched, because there is
also a lot of
research behind it which I
conducted out of,
let's say, -- because I like
making my
homework, I know a bit what I'm
talking
about, and of course I was also
dealing with
different cultures, it was
important to have
a sort of precise knowledge of
specific
situations, and the visa effect
I described
it before, so it gives you an
idea of how all
those things combine. But it's
also the same
methodology I used for all of my
projects.
I'm always working with things I
have
experienced with or know about
in my
environment, including the ones
--   : But it was
also stories I heard when I was
a kid.
African national Congress,
headquarters were
located in Morocco in 1962, so I
always
worked with things that I knew
about in my
environment and I researched,
too, and
somehow all of this becomes a
sort of --
stays in my head, but it's not
only more
important when I'm on the south,
when it's
happening. And to answer your
other question
about how it happened that I met
so many
individuals who told me their
stories, it's
just that we talk a lot together
. So the
videos are not based on
interviews, there's
no questions being asked. It was
very long
conversations and I think
throughout those
conversations there was also a
form of
empowerment that was developing,
because they
were somehow becoming the author
of their own
story. It was not being told by
someone else.
It was being told by themselves,
so, yeah,
there was also a form of
camaraderie.
>> So I'd like to remind the
audience that
you can ask questions and I
think there are
cards amongst you that have been
distributed
so please do so. Write out your
questions,
and Bouchra, I know you wanted
to show a few
slides.
>> Not necessarily. I mean we
can keep
talking. I also find it very
nice just to
have this conversation.
>> It's really up to you.
>> No, I'm totally OK.
>> All right, you had mentioned
earlier that
you didn't think that social
media, the
internet, you know, Facebook,
etc., all of
these things, had really played
such an
important role, I think in the
context of the
Arab Spring.
>> I haven't said that.
>> Oh, OK, well, but you said
that you know
they were revolutionary ideas
and connections
that predated social media. I
wonder, though,
how you think these technologies
are -- and
this question is for you, as
well -- how
these technologies may or may
not alter the
stories of some of these people
who are, you
know, who are refugees, whether
-- I mean I
know that if I recall correctly
in some of
your -- in your installation,
there were
accounts of people saying, you
know, I was
able to call my mother, I was
able to, you
know, maybe, you know, face time
with her or
whatever, so in what ways do
these
technologies make a difference?
I mean, are
they, for instance, you know,
helping in any
way to make less imposing the --
you know,
the power of the nation state,
the
overwhelming sort of
oppressiveness of the
nation state? Do you find that
in any way
they play a role, or not?
>>
way to say is I
do think that the phenomenon of
migration, of
course it's an old phenomenon,
but it has
been accelerate ed by technology
and that's not
just kind of a communication
technology,
though that is part of it,
because now
everybody understands the
possibilities out
there. There's this global
communication and
people have pictures and they
have
understandings and they have
communications
and networks, and so this sense
that there's
a possibility to move if you
want to, is I
think enhanced by technology,
and of course
then the physical possibilities
of moving are
enhanced by id modern means of
transportation.
So globalization and the way
that connects
people together, economically,
socially,
culturally, that certainly has
an impact in
challenging and then making
people nervous
about their understanding of
what their
community is and membership in
the community
and outsiders, so yeah, I think
so.
>> In connection with the Arab
Spring, of
course the social media were
extremely
important, because I mean one of
the
vocations is to allow
communities to exist or
to invent other communities,
strategically
speaking it's extremely
important in Syria
and other countries, maybe not
as important
in Tunisia, because the
demonstrations were
so immense and -- so if there
are maybe
producing the sort of own
pistmology, it is
in the conception of the
community. It
doesn't need to be present in
one space. That
can exist and be effective
virtually. In a
virtual space and that has an
impact on the
reality. Maybe that connection,
in that way,
from the virtual community to
the physical,
political community that becomes
visible
, so
to give you an example of maybe
2014 work
based on the
... that really happened, but
that was never documented, and
well, what
surprised me a lot is when I
started seeing
in demonstrations in Morocco,
pictures and
seeing in Paris a few weeks ago,
the look
forward, there was a
demonstration against
racism and for equality, and
there are
pictures of
: And this is a result of the
reconnection of community. You
know.
>> We have a number of
questions, by the
way, from the audience, so I'll
start with
one but    , and this is a
question of: Do you see
the artist as being necessarily
progressive.
>> That's a very good question.
I think hi
history has shown that not
artists are
progressive. I don't believe
that an artist
has to be necessarily
progressive or being a
good artist or that you're a
good artist it's
because you are progressive. No,
not really.
Great artists, whom I personally
admire as
artists, not as human beings,
that are not
progressive.
Their art has been regarded as
great art but they are not
progressive.
>> So the first question is --
the power of
between today's issues with the
refugees and
the crisis and the Holocaust
exist but
there's an underlying
difference. Today's
refugees come from political
belief systems,
but
that seek to dominate others.
The excessive
accommodation of refugees
demands are
suicidal. How do you balance?
>> One of the problems with
this sort of
question is one asks what is the
empirical
evidence and if one looks at the
facts over
the last, recently hundreds of
thousands of
refugees admitted to the United
States over
the past 20, 30 years, and four
incidents of
terror, so there's just no
reason to believe.
Bouchra's story captures it
nicely, the vast
majority of refugees, what do
they want? They
want their children to be safe.
They want to
find a place where they can live
a life, grow
up with their kids, have a job,
and live a
normal life. And so the idea
that somehow --
so some from oppressive regime,
but the fact
that the -- the idea that they
would then
want to reinstitutionalize those
oppressive
regimes is without foundation.
Not to say
nobody, but almost nobody and
the idea that
we should exclude all these
people for the
possibility of the one or the
two is just
inhumane.
>> I absolutely agree with you,
too, because
if one makes leaving an
oppressive regime to
reinstitute an oppressive regime
as well,
they are not refugees, they have
a plan.
>> I saw something somebody had
said, you
know, people do not put their
kids in boats,
unless you know being on a boat
is less
dangerous than being on the
land. People are
not fleeing to dominate others.
They're
fleeing to save their lives, so
it's just
unreasonable to construct them
in that way.
>> And to give an example that
is probably
not absolutely relevant for all
the
situations that are occurring
today with
regards to the migration crisis,
but as an
example, in north Africa, --
again I speak of
what I know from experience.
>> Leaving the country without
a visa was
also
against the regime, but also
there are
millions of people who could
travel freely
and to make a life of their own
where they
wanted to live. So there is also
a form of --
I won't call it a political
statement at all.
Because that's not the case. But
as you said,
no one risks their life and the
life of their
kids to implement an oppressive
regime, as
well, it is simply not to become
a
millionaire or whatever, but to
have a decent
life, and a life where respect
is guaranteed,
but also liberty, and that's
also the
difference between us being like
in Lebanon
or Jordan or Turkey, and being
in Germany,
mostly Germany and Europe. In
one cases there
are many restrictions to the
liberties in
being a refugee, and that's also
the reason
why, if you take the risk to or
if you are
willing to risk your life
because it's a
matter of survival, liberty is
also somehow
at stake.
>> Absolutely.
>> Can I say one other quick
thing? Jews
were just leaving to assimilate.
But that way
of phrasing it forgets all of
the
anti-Semitic
tropes. It was precisely that
this false construction that
they were bent
on domination, and I think that
again these
tropes are repeated today, but
now with
respect to others.
>> We have one more question
here and I'm
going to add to it a little bit.
So did you
have to choose between which
refugee stories
to tell and display, and if so,
how did you
choose? And I'm adding to it, I
recall, was
it one woman or maybe more? At
least one was
a woman, and could you speak a
little bit
about the difference between the
males versus
the females in the story, in the
narrative?
Because I imagine being a woman,
I think it
was a Somali woman in that case.
I mean the
experience of traveling must
have been
harrowing. It's harrowing for
all of them,
but that much more so for her.
If you could
say something about that.
>> Well, actually, there was no
casting.
There are no videos that were
filmed that are
not being shown there. All of
them are there.
And I have not selected, because
it was not
what was at stake. What was at
stake was
meeting an individual and going
back            not going back
to
the media question. It is
somehow the
opposite of looking for a good
example.
Because there are no good
examples. Every
single life deserves or every
single story
deserves to be told. Because
they are
universe al. So, no, they are
all there.
Speaking of the video with the
woman from
Somalia, I think of course I was
very
touched
by her, but she's a very strong
woman,
extremely strong. But she was
also protected
by other Somali men, and going
back to the
previous question and the answer
you gave to
it, those also in Europe a very
popular --   :
Called
Arabs had a plan to invade
Europe and
to submit Europe to Islam. That
woman was
protected by older men, not very
older, but
old y and they made sure that
... She was not
a or not -- was in a group. And
she was the
only woman and she was perfectly
safe among
those men. So there was no
the Arab
conception of woman that is: Or
whatever,
absolutely not. She was, yeah,
in a community
of mep.
>> Another one is what has
changed in the
refugees' visibility in the
media or
elsewhere since you made this
work in 2008 to
2011? That's
>> That's a very good question.
Actually, I
think it will speak of
visibility, but the
challenge should be specified.
Was the
migration crisis discussed every
single day,
but it is also discussed by the
politicians
in Europe and also here. I heard
that Donald
Trump made some comments on his
views on
migration. Can we call it
visibility? I'm not
sure. What is certainly
visibility            visible is
certain
discourses but it doesn't mean
that they are
visible, that there are
individuals that are
suffering the conditions of
being forced to
live is visible. And therefore
one can also
ask another question, at what
point is she
visible, too? Because speaking
of the
visibility of the refugees, is
-- doesn't
answer the question of why are
they forced to
expose this very hard life that
can last for
literally years for some of
them. And so I'm
not sure if -- let's say
humanitarian
comments are enough to make
visible the
question of ownership, because
again the
question of what is at stake is
again
equality. Until that point are
we ready to
accept an other that can be
radically other?
That can be undergo a certain
type of
otherness that is not popular in
the country
or whatever. Whatever they have
in mind the
very specific concepts in
Germany and France,
which I am aware because I have
lived in
those places and this also
affects the
visibility or nonvisibility of
the
individual's liberty. I'm not
sure if I'm
answering the question. It's a
very difficult
question to answer because
advicibilities
means many, many different
things. I think
for me what should be visible is
their own
views and the perspective of the
individuals
who are experiencing this crisis
in their
life that really impacts their
life, and how
are we willing to shape our
perspective on
otherness but also on equality.
>> I mean I'll just say that
thinking that
Bush
Bouchra's project is to render
people visible
who are not, right? That's what
the mapping
journey does, it makes it
possible to see
people in a certain kind of way
who normally
are just unseen. So they're
visible in one
sense as objects, as threats, as
depersonalized others, and then
you have a
project that helps you make them
see them as
human beings.
>> We have a question, I think
this one is
addressed to you. So this
question says,
commitment to society as a basis
of
citizenship is a lovely idea. On
the flip
side, the anxiety or suspicion
about refugees
and
economic migrants comes from a
suspicion
of whether they're committed to
this notion
of a society. Do we need to
think of these
categories separately when
considering
immigration? I guess the
category of
immigrant versus economic
migrant.
>> Yeah. So I guess I would be
answering
that question distinguish two
levels of
thought. So if you are asking as
a kind of
practical policy matter today,
should we try
to distinguish between economic
migrants and
refugees, I think it does make
sense to
distinguish between those who
have an urgent
need for safety, for their basic
need for
safety and protection of human
rights to gain
entry, between others who have a
life and
they're trying to better
themselves. Those
are not the same situations and
we do need to
make distinctions. But it's also
important to
step back -- and that's in the
kind of
context where we're accepting
the existing
background framework in place,
but it's also
important to step back and
criticize that
framework. I guess one of the
things that I'm
trying to get people to think
about is that
the fundamental background
structure of the
way we've organized the world
and to see that
that is deeply unjust, in a just
world,
this -- this difference would
disappear,
because people would not feel
the need to
leave, either because they were
being driven
out as refugees or because they
had a need to
move elsewhere for economic
reasons. There's
no reason in principle why we
couldn't
organise the world in a just way
so that
people have decent opportunities
at home.
Then if they wanted to move,
they could have
the freedom to move if they
wanted to. Most
people probably wouldn't,
because most people
want to live where they grow up,
where they
have family, where they have
cultural roots.
That's the way most people want
to live but
then some people want to move
for one reason
or another, and their movement
would not be a
problem if so many didn't have
urgent other
needs to move. So I think that's
what's at
the heart of the
problem.
>> I make a distinction between
economic
migrants and --
>> Well, I think there is a
continuum. That
you recognize that there are
people who are
being bombed, so if they don't
get to leave,
they will die. And other people
-- so if we
look in the United States, for
example. Most
of the people who come from
Mexico to the
United States, who I think ought
to receive
legal status after they're
regularized. But
in most cases they would not die
living in
Mexico, they would simply have a
more limited
life and they're coming to seek
a better life
for themselves and their
children. Which I
think is a perfectly reasonable
thing for
them to be but their need to be
outside their
country of origin isn't as
urgent and dire as
the needs of some people who
really can't
survive without it. So I think
we have to
recognize that function amount.
ality? You don't?
[laughter]
>> Can we say one more
question?
>> Yeah.
>>
I started a story that is
actually about
citizenship. The first one in
Paris, the
second one in Italy, and the
third here. And
the third was about articulation
between
labor and citizenship. And the
whole case,
it's a video about, is structure
around
somehow public speech given by
-- that is
defined today by undocumented
workers. A few
of them from Mexico, and
defining other forms
of citizenship based on their
belonging to
the workforce. One of them
specifically says
that I find personally very
powerful. Even
though he's undocumented, he
considers that
he belongs to the, to think
community,
because his political
consciousness grew up
here.
>> I agree with that, though.
But in saying
that I think you have to
distinguish, it
doesn't mean that the people who
have come
here and settled here as
undocumented workers
are not members or don't belong
or don't have
a right to stay, which I think
they do, they
have a right to get legal status
and to get
citizenship. It just has to do
with the
urgency of people who are now
outside. What
is the relative urgency of
people who are
outside, I think we can
distinguish between
different conditions. But the
people who are
already here, they are members
from my point
of view and they ought to be
accepted. I
agree with that.
>> Good. Maybe one last
question, so this
again is a question that says,
why isn't
there more focus directed on the
people or
leaders who are responsible for
creating
refugees rather than the rev
refugees themselves?
In other words, on the systems
that produce
this.
>> Well, again, I think that
you know, the
story of -- one of the arguments
you heard in
the 1930s was, you know,
admitting Jewish
refugees will not solve the
problem of
Hitler, and that's true. It
wouldn't. And so
of course, the problem is the
leaders and the
oppressive regimes that are
generating these
refugees, but the question is
what are you
going to do with the people that
are You can't finesse that
problem and
there's nothing to be gabbed by
making -- do
you want Syrian toes bombed by
Assad and is
that going to do something to
remove Assad
from power? I don't think so.
>> Please join me in thanking
our panel.
[applause]